millimeter soziologe für sein neuestes
buch über die 68er suchte nach passenden
fotos erinnerungen an die börse
ran.de muss
es ist so wie eine heldin uns fordern
und auf dem platz wo man kennt dafür so
platz her und den sind einfach alles mit
widerständen und 17 auf dem place und
sagen wir wollen den handel politiker
das hat eindruck gemacht und ja zur s
health rebellen vor
[Musik]
was ist leben vor dem ziel das leben
eigentlich vor läuft das ist als cloud
ist verklagt was wenn ich hoffe dass
sich höhere opposition sehr gespannt und
ideologisch für angst gehabt
es ist schon blöd vor allem also die
horizonterweiterung 2 real ist wenn man
die passive also etwa so gut wie nie in
die realität zu integrieren das ist so
eine leitung der gedanke 7 und spürt
haben
lima ein linkes urgestein der schweiz
warum auch menschen die das heuer auf
ganz anderen politischen bühnen lagern
geben es eine nähe suchen davon handelt
dieser film
[Musik]
juli mathis 66 im ruhestand ist der
emeritierte soziologieprofessor aber
keineswegs ist ein buch führt er über
100 interviews mit den
unterschiedlichsten vertretern der 68er
bewegung heute besuchte verleger jürg
marquard an der zürcher goldküste 88 was
bleibt ist zu hoch
was ist wichtig sie und was ist los war
und eigentlich sei es auch in österreich
immer noch irgendwo sieht jetzt ja ich
bin damals sehr beschäftigt sie mit move
wovon jeder zutritt
ich hatte zwei gründe dafür sagt sie
danke schön wenn man verschiedenste
gründe 3com erzähl ich ob sich der index
also mir ist eigentlich mehr um musik
gange und die politisch jährlich von der
bewegung natürlich war klar ich habe
mich eingesetzt für legalisierung
weicher drogen und aber mögliche aber
ich bin nie radikal
sie halfen sie bitte hier
das ist egal das ist also mein
arbeitsplatz gekostet haben
dann sage ich ihnen wenig einfach nix
sehen und wenn ich dafür bin dass wir
nach der pause bis ganz natürliches
betrachtet ich will das machen und zwar
ein titelbild zwar und die titel von
ford und einem inzwischen seinen 80
schön sei die pixar bewusst erlaubt und
möchte so schrieben wir die neue
generation
sie haben nichts mehr politischen
einfluss eine ibm sehen mit dem ich muss
sagen ich bin eben auch keine politische
landschaft haben keine politischen
gestaltungswillen ich bin ab so wird mit
bin persönlich für das ist mit harz
börde sozialen bereich ja eigentlich
sehe in der schweiz dass es irgendwo 400
mitglied wo fulltime erwerbstätig sind
oder früheren käme das ist ein patent
für mich wenn es auch etwas oft und ich
sag' otto verantworte ich kannte ich nur
politisch sinnvoll auch das 80
ein und machen ein flexibles combo job
sie im zeit begrüßte die täter sind
eigentlich ohne text du ich hätte
wirklich sehr glücklich durch die jagd
oder beruflich das buch gar nicht aber
weil die konkurrenz gesellschaft bleibe
dann will ich mich bewiesen und riesa
bin so happy wie die andere
aber das war eine reale wies dann könne
das sind sie und für mich ist die
soziale ungleichheit ausgleichen das ist
willy mattes motor sein heutiger
interviewpartner hatte dafür kein
musikgehör einfach als große
herausforderung einem selber bis zu
machen
vor dem spiel hat nein das vergangene
dadurch vielleicht das wenig
eine hausgemeinschaft im zürcher kreis 7
ein stück lebendige achtundsechziger
geschichte die historikerin elisabeth so
ries lebt hier seit 34 jahren mit ihrem
mann und drei anderen paaren zusammen
mit glück kommt heißt gut gemacht
ich glaube dass man diese ti stieg mit
mit dem konzept mit einem kind das ist
das ist schon wichtig sind für mich ganz
wichtig die umsetzung regelmäßig und der
austausch und inneres sowie deren
antwort muss immer unterlaufen können
besprechen was ein pastor
organisatorisch zu seinem epos so dass
nicht vor problemen oder unstimmigkeiten
oder sachen gern mitmachen schnitt macht
dass mehr rekruten sind und zu alt sind
also wirklich gut sind und dass auch das
auf die schnitte weg aber sie sind da wo
jetzt zur eigentlichen hand und sich vor
sie metergenau 10 militär gestoppt und
wieder auf dem land in europa land
sondern die wand wieder in einer
ähnlichen situation lasse elisabeth uhr
ist beruflicher und politischer
werdegang als historikerin feministin
und gewerkschafterin wäre ohne den 68er
aufbruch nicht denkbar gewesen
im studio for android oder klafter
transporter bezirks auto oder ja lagers
vorstudie der fünfzigerjahre wachse
außerdem 60er jahre die leitbörsen stark
so mäßig vorhaben darunter sehr wichtig
sie wohnformen trauer womit die gängige
muster foto apa mit
ein so kreft und vor allem auch viele
ziehen oder eine kunstfigur 30 mustafa
jurist und männer sind ihren idealen von
damals treu geblieben
deswegen wurde urimat als professor an
der universität basel oft kritisiert er
verbreite seine linke ideologie unter
dem deckmantel der wissenschaft
natürlich nicht wieso ich versuche dass
transparenz machen aber wenig forsch
hatte ich doch schon so oft sachen unser
gefunden wo ihre touren weil es ganz
ordentlich aussieht mir das wünsche also
für die tierversuche mini sicht checken
und nicht einfach dass wir schon im
hinterkopf ins feld das projizieren
wurden untersucht das war ja langweilig
denn bestätigt man sich laufend sind die
sachen musik von der hand wo ihn wieder
heim das linke also paar wochen schon
mal gesagt wir müssen wie immer sich
eine strophe wenn man sich positiver
waren und dann haben sie mich für mal
gesagt wie er ist die integration von
jugendlichen mit migrationshintergrund
war aber gleichwohl gut die
qualifikation hat pro flug und zu einer
gemerkt die hand die größte
integrationschancen bitterböser
multinationaler konzern
sie haben später konnte gewaltige
schlachten oder soziale institutionen
zum teil noch schlechtere bedingungen
das haben ihre so muss er mir etwas
herzwochen und das heißt etwa woche
sofort über uns gebracht
[Musik]
68 was bleibt erstmal das neues buch
dass die ereignisse der 68er bewegung
auch ausserhalb der grossen schweizer
städte thematisiert
im bus sagt das jahr etwas verändert was
hält die schweizer anders geht ja doch
es hat diesen ali gewaltigen ihnen viel
verändert im sinnvoll sei anders sehe
und das ist nicht so wie es immer schon
so gemacht bis kritisch hinterfrage das
könne
juni bd ihr euch vielleicht schwieriger
vorstellen will anno dazumal sind das
show einfach so gesellschaftliche
gewissheit sie und was die leute sagen
das ist so und da sind vorstellen dass
es vor der ganz zentralen veränderungen
mit ideologischen verhärtungen habe sich
die 68er bewegung selber geschwächt
schreibt gerne hätte er auch über eines
dieser dunklen kapitel geschrieben den
terrorismus der raf
wer jetzt eine recherche mehrere rosberg
auf ihr nachgegangen dass radikale das
quasi reinen oder das moralisch her
das hätte nicht so ein stück wird
interessiert und ich bin mal reich oder
mobil auf der bucher hoffen dass glaube
sind 14 militärpolizisten mit
maschinengewehren anschlag sie das ist
noch nicht lange zurück sie wesentlich
höhere blüht verstecken
aber diese haben in anderen aktie also
drei wochen überreicht worden ist stehen
wirklich eine sehr anständige quartieren
sie im geld nicht da ist
sie hat jetzt das auch eine baustelle
immer unterstützt gerade das das show
also ja unterschlupf gewähre
die partnergate 1 durch autonome szene
wo mir zwei miteinander geredet hat ist
dass ich straße variante vom widerstand
zum kampf aber bald der reform das habe
ich schon abgeräumt
das ist auch die kritik am
imperialistischen westen und die
verherrlichung gewisser
menschenverachtende regime sehr naiv sky
film war doch stress macht kate ein
entfernt oder einfach dass man das hoch
stilisiert allen das monsterprojekt
gewalt und die suchtberater und alison
couper basiert oder in vietnam passiert
also tatsächlich keine machen und dank
eines freiheitlichen als menschlicher
gesucht und jetzt ein doch mancher
wechsle selektiv company hat hat er sich
selber immer größte kritische distanz
käufer natürlich im engagement für
befreiungsbewegungen sicher wie es
vielleicht einfach viel und besonders
übernommen da bin ich überhaupt nicht
sagt sie
[Musik]
für sein buch trifft man auch menschen
welche die seite gewechselt haben
seit einer hitzigen fernsehdebatte kommt
es beispielsweise zu sporadischen
treffen mit dem chefredaktor der basler
zeitung markus somm der einst für dich
so aktiv war
scarponis aber ja dass ich dafür schenkt
ich weiß es im monat und 17 jahren immer
vermisst dollar vom staat zum beispiel
nicht möglich anders sehen die
heimischen firmen daran früheren der
staat sicher positiv erzählt aber dürfte
keine große schritt macht ich befehle
marco war dann hat sich für ihren
aktiven ich höre zu sagen bei mir ihre
große kritische deutschland kritische
equity staunens früher nur zum start
oder also der staat das ist immer noch
wo kontrolliert oder nämlich haben wir
der stadt mehr in schutz nehmen so
schlimm ist wenn berlins nach rechts
gegangen um gegen wird zeige ja was ist
spannender aber ich glaube schon dass
ich dem einigen wo man österreich obwohl
rein
es könnte ein nachteil die verhüttungs
und da wir jetzt selber bin millimetern
untersagt haben und das fing ja sie die
ganze generation deswegen viel
interessanter gesprächspartner
die hängt das seitdem einig wo völlig
falsch sich aber sie hat sich seit
seiner es kostet wo sie noch teil gar
ein offensichtlicher nachteil und die
bequemen bürgerlotsen sind so der fdp
oder cvp und wichtigste unterschied sind
die bequemen respekt und das nicht gut
findet dass diese szene geworden ist
getroffen hat oder wenn ich denn
institut gescheitert ist kann jetzt mit
dem herrgott meter kasse denn dass
natürlich bis muskulös den hand sofort
lück seit großen
überdies sehe und ich denke auch dass
ich umgekehrt ist am ende auch war dann
oder so also liegt nicht so bis zu spät
aber doch verloren ich mich einfach auf
mich und wenn's nicht interessiert denn
ich mir das wichtig und ich finde es
interessant und spannend und den
marktzugang
40 jahre lang lebte oder ständig in
wohngemeinschaften
heute teilt er sich eine zwei zimmer
wohnung im aargauischen rheinfelden mit
seiner frau in diesem film nicht
auftreten will
zufall ist das nicht das ist dass auch
er ist im rathaus entwurf denen wir sind
sieht es auch das 80 zweimal sehr
intensiv zusammen mit reichen über lange
zeit und jetzt gut zusammen
aber es gibs tiger die wahl kommt und so
die excel liegen aber dass ich sowieso
desto somit auch mal mitglied das ist
für sie immer jemals das problem sich
bei ausländern frauen team hat wirklich
alles gepasst irgendwo dazu gehört dass
frauen kommt und aber bitte nicht zu
akzeptieren man das früher oder widgets
sowie der handball markt schon so detail
haben so müssen alle die andere frau der
big sie sind aber denn habe ja gemerkt
dass auch ihre mutter immer über
alzheimer sind dass ich ja nicht einfach
große rücksprache so familie was ist
musik für kinder sie sind
sobald der bürger hoffen
klima ist etwas wie der prototyp des
68er teilzeit hausmann militärdienst
verweigert gründungsmitglied grossrat in
basel
er engagierte sich gegen den
vietnamkrieg und für fairen tourismus in
die dritte welt
daneben war er erfolgreicher handballer
in der nationalliga
[Musik]
marta ist auch vater von drei kindern
und großvater von zwei enkeln tochter
saskia ist wie die beiden älteren
geschwister in einer sehr konstanten
wohngemeinschaft groß geworden
also was ich was sehr speziellen sich
jetzt nur hinein als moralisch das
müssen sie etwas nach zwei familien und
und die erwachsenen sind damit vier
erwachsene die an sich immer das teilt
das immer an jedem tag ist zuständig
sechs wochen und auf die hausarbeit der
hand sieht sich oft halt wie es war der
profess tragust wenig zum spiel gefunden
und zu muss immer dann auch trixi und
immer nicht alle spieler zusammen bei
kinderspielen wenn ich keine
millimeter ist nicht nur soziologe er
machte auch eine ausbildung in
psychotherapie dort wurde ihm einst ein
gewaltbereiter hooligans zugeteilt
gefängnis oder gesprächstherapie vor
dieser wahl stand sein früherer klientel
mann den er heute für ein interview im
laufental besucht
[Musik]
das ist ja das ist so
im land opposition szenen in den
schwarzwald
[Musik]
unbedingt hinter gitter
1993 profitierte das schweizer fernsehen
glück und seine freunde beiden basel in
dieser zeit fanden auch die gespräche
mit uli meter statt
wir haben uns gut verstanden oder das
coole autos fahrrad wurde und unter
sehen erfüllt was kriegt ja dass ich
sport mache über überwald also dass ich
zu qualitativ ob er denn zum entschluss
oder und zum einschluss häufig walter
hat der durchschnittsmensch oder ja weil
ich war wirklich nicht irgendwie werde
ich einfach passanten los war rock
hudson brückner war sondern ich habe
brücke zur einfachen anwendung
ich tue das nicht rechtfertigen doch
täuscht aber mein soziologisch jetzt
wenn ich sehe die sozialen und wie heute
wenn ich sehe die ungerechtigkeit also
doch jetzt andere form wobei euch mit
gesellschaft kommt und das habe ich
nicht mal für mindestens ebenso schlimm
gefunden
die post vorteile sagen dass vor straube
wanderarbeiter freundschaft oder mehr
kein also für mich das techno forscht
also für mich das jetzt wirklich glaube
aber dass langenbruch irgendwie finde
ich toll oder dass ich kann sagen
millimeter dicker freund von mir wurde
also das ist ja schon ein dass ich ja es
würde das schon grund zum stolz hier als
ich so zu erfahren wer wo oft wald und
oder und das prägt ein ganz also für dr
ich kann sicher nicht von den
analytikern übernachtung sind und der
karriere gemacht hat mächtig als vor der
so genannte einfacher liegt ich kann von
mir aus können das ist wie trügerisch
aber ich hoffe das heißt ich sehe es
einfach liebe sie in island hat ja
völlig anders ist so nicht sein oder
ich bin mindestens zwei mal klagen
glücklich mit seiner goldmine
politischer haltige bin ich nicht und
ich danke
was war als siebente klasse lehrer kann
hat wollte sie nicht schützend die hand
über mich pölten hat also darum danke
ich wichtigen auf dem boden bleibt ja
immer mehr
[Musik]